o lado diz pessoal do que falam dark
exijo muito bem - é mais perto e eu já
fiz balé da ópera de lyon onde vamos
garantir que o interporto e vocês podem
prejudicar muito estilo e por isso vamos
focar tira nossa proeza foi aquela do
sorriso que só o rio no último vídeo mas
desta vez eu já treinar um pouco e eu
acho que agora vou conseguir ser a
melhor obra do sul está pronto e roubá
lá é hoje que eu vou conseguir
é preciso novo senhor recurdo subiu para
lá senhor crê cuno caiu muita cobra já
que ouviu um sim ok vamos manter a calma
ainda somos benéfica que está em
primeiro lugar é o homem invisível ontem
nome com assim um objetivo vai ser ficar
em primeiro lugar aqui o senhor tranco
do tanque está em primeiro lugar porque
o crack o crack vem sempre eu vou
brincar obviamente nem nunca me túnis e
droga droga faz malan e fumo e rosas
filme alguma coisa assim
ontem aí eu vou dizer porque este jogo
não tem comentado em um fundo as olha aí
quase não comeu assume como e olha no
que deu e vão virar mas foi o senhor crê
culpa só temos que cobrar coerência vão
seguir lá vamos ver para onde é que a
cor branco isso vai levar o jogo show
ocorrer tão grande como assim espera eu
vou tentar como ela será que eu consigo
será está a um pequeno passo para a
cobra e um grande passo quero dizer
agora tudo vai vai ficou perto de ser o
primeiro mas vamos lá
a esperança é a última a viver a morrer
em paz meu currículo no centro conseg
tem uma boa menina cabeça não quero
comer o que é o twitter começou cup
contou oscar isso e agora
kaká em 40 com uma cobra a comeu tudo
filha da mãe e se contenta com vista a
conseguir aqui é claque [ __ ] neneca 2
minha e isso num grupo agora vai agora
vai comer é agora comer mas o imbituba é
pequeno e precisa apanhar alguém que
esta é bem grande é isso é muita comida
só pra mim é óbvio list othon e de um
delicioso tombos tozzo e isso com um
gorro emitir alguma forma para eu
conseguir ficar em primeiro o primeiro o
iuperj do sul e agora não consegue
simplesmente jogar porque os comem muito
e theo não acho charme e bocão umas a
focar machucar a sola bora bora bora
bora agora vai agora vai agora vai
estamos no caminho certo agora o gol foi
o não não rouba comida filha da mãe
a comida vai voltar muito pequeno o meu
disco no jogo tanto olha só o núcleo e
eu fui comigo agora ok pessoal a partir
de agora é manter a calma manter a calma
e tentar comer
esta é uma criança comer mas eu não
deixei ela queria me começo mas eu não
deixei o meu boné da sorte vai vai agora
vai agora vai agora é só aguentar muito
o olho da que aguentou max a comichão
falou olha parece uma comissão externa
cuba me uma optimista roma um pitéu
filha da pu
eu vou tentar pegar agora esta cobra bem
grande quando eu só ando só atrás
comenta taxa ainda é de que ela tá nem
ataque da qual o documento ou tanto que
tenho que fazer é boa bem indicado calma
agora na volta volta pega que sptel e
isso dá a dica é aproveitar é pra você
vai vai
ainda muito pitoco miranda só então daí
julgado em caráter mais pitéu estes são
cobras ou não tentar pegar esta aqui eu
vou tentar ficar esta calma calma calma
não há quaisquer davam que eu tô
companhia agora bota quase com o meu tom
é jesus jesus acredita em mim ai ai ela
tava fechado aqui dentro não pode
ana é uma boa mas pitéu pouco
ela estima que dentro como assim vai ver
isso estava todo não val não vá ao ar
pessoal vamos ficar porque com estes
vídeos para que vocês tenham gostado
fiquem bem não peçam pra ficar mais esta
bosta de jogo não não busca mais beijo
no rabo e até a próxima